first up he is the former New Jersey
Governor my home state and New York
Times bestselling author of let me
finish Trump the Kushner's ban in New
Jersey and the power of in-your-face
politics Governor Chris Christie's over
here
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here my
pleasure now I really appreciate it
because I'm sure you know in the past I
may have done one or maybe two jokes
yeah you're not your buddy you're a
second place still behind Letterman on
the fat jokes so you're gonna be fine
fat jokes I hadn't thought of that
can I tell you the best one sure yeah
chris Christie can't run he has
skeletons in his closet of cows I think
Letterman's best one was he said on
Super Bowl weekend he came back for
super one he said this this weekend the
America said with two million pounds of
chicken wings were eaten and that was
just a governor Christie's house he ours
is better anyway maybe that's why he's
off the air and well knows so why a book
I mean usually people write a book and
the title let me finish makes it sound
like you have more to go in your career
right is usually when people write a
book it means they're setting the table
to run again now you see I couldn't
write a book when I was governor I'm the
only governor in America where there's a
law that says you can't write a book
while you're gone right yeah well and so
people started asking me about writing a
book after Hurricane sandy and I
couldn't do it
and so I've been thinking about it for
five years they've been stewing up there
and I just decided once I got out I
wanted to write it I really built did it
just for the money that was
okay what but I mean I remember in 2012
you were the guy that they were talking
about Ann Coulter who's the kingmaker
now remember she said if it's not Chris
Christie I'm out you remember that yeah
that's what discouraged in the accident
I wonder if you have regrets cuz I
remember we did a piece here on the show
saying you know what America always
likes the new they claim they want the
tried and true but look at the people
who run like Bob Dole and Walter Mondale
and Mitt Romney I could go on John
became the PERT John Kerry people who
wait their turn they don't they like the
new one when they got an Obama ran yes
said it's too soon and you said no
that's Gretz what's good they don't have
anything on me yet yep do you think you
missed your moment
no well listen I obviously I did I'm not
president so I missed my moment but I
but I wouldn't do it differently I was
operating under what now is obviously an
antiquated theory which was I wasn't
ready to be president because they'd
only been governor for 15 months
obviously now that seems like a
completely ridiculous notion but but
back then I really felt it bill and I
just felt like it wasn't the right time
I didn't feel it so I felt like I
couldn't go out there and be genuine and
ask people for their vote if I didn't
feel it so you can't second-guess that
cuz that's what's in your heart and you
know and I understand the politics of it
and what you said I think is exactly
right and that was a moment but I think
it would be worse to run and win if you
aren't ready than to lose but I think
you're gonna run in 2024 and I think
you're looking for Donald Trump to do to
fall as he inevitably must you must know
this man does not have the moral core to
be president you must know that if
Vladimir Putin came member when he said
well he'd called me brilliant when they
asked him about Putin the first time but
he likes that oh do you think yeah do
you think if Vladimir Putin came to him
and said as it may have happened I think
you're brilliant can I help you with
this election Donald Trump would say no
that's wrong yeah I kind of doubt that
conversation actually happened but I
didn't have to be a conversation what I
what I what I would say to you though is
that we've had a number of presidents
over the
course of our history who had some
questionable moral core like him well I
listen we're gonna see over the next
couple of years how it goes from here
but you know listen I'm not gonna defend
everything that he does or says I
haven't you see that in the book and you
see when I'm when I'm on television
talking about it I've known the guy for
a long time I know his strengths the
weaknesses he's got some serious
weaknesses along with some strengths
okay but like Roger stone now yeah okay
general Flynn right both of Ted here in
this Michael College you didn't tell me
that that's right by ya you want to get
duck walked out of here you know and
you're not in trouble because you were
lucky they fired you that's right maybe
it was a good move that very good move
good for me bad for the country I
suspect so yet maybe yeah I don't think
you were anybody could ever convince
Donald Trump to do anything he doesn't
want to do that's been proven nobody
around him not even his daughter and we
know that's the weak point well yeah but
but what I would say to you is though
garbage in garbage out and the more
people that you have bad around him and
who give him granted bed you know
suggestions you know you wind up with a
bad result and you know what I was
trying to do when I was around I was
trying to put good stuff in front of him
and trying to move in another direction
I know how hard it is to move him I've
known him for a long time but part of
why I did what I did was to try to give
him right better choices I get that and
you know there were other people around
them that didn't want that okay so I was
saying stone right Lynn Manafort Cohen
these are people very close to him
they're all going to jail perfectly okay
is it really possible you could have
this many people around you who were
doing shady stuff and the top guy not
know about it well I think it's possible
but it doesn't matter because he's
accountable for it like if you put
people in that position but that's but
you're accountable but they could say
the same thing about your of your bridge
scandal they could and and I said I'm
accountable for that I'm not responsible
for it there's a diff you know nothing
about I know absolutely nothing about it
that's a lot of people who are plotting
no debate
excuse me let's be clear okay it was
three people it was three people and
three and
the geishas came to the same result that
it was three people okay and so I don't
want to get no I don't want to get into
that aim I understand but the point is
though I don't want a short hands and
have people walk away with the wrong
impression but I'm still accountable for
it okay because two of those three
couple I put in place so you know so you
have to take accountability if we see
this play out every day Donald Trump not
every day but a lot of days he tweets
horrible things about Muller
ya know Muller yeah you were prosecuted
yeah and I've said your honor you're a
normal Republican yeah I don't know what
that means coming from you but I'll take
it
you're you know I hope you are no no you
don't do you hope you already committed
that I was right what I call Republican
classic not the new Koch Republican
classic but not the Trump okay I like
that
so Robert Muller I've heard you say you
think he's a decent honest heart I think
he's got honesty integrity a good man
running a good investigation so Trump
alright that's not what Trump says about
it I know he's wrong
so who's dirty Trump or Moeller one of
them one of the hostile bloggers it's
not dirty oh yeah so thanks so the my
point and I've said this to the I've
said this directly to the president so
I'm not say I'm in the united said to
him it's wrong
first we call this a witch-hunt it's
dumb for him to do it and one things I
said to him way back in February of
seventeen was there there's no way to
make this shorter but there's lots of
ways to make it longer and poke at the
bear and calling it a witch-hunt and
calling them bad people just makes it
longer and it's a wrong thing to do I
mean the FBI you still believe in them
right yeah most of them okay most well
most elicit I work no organisation is
perfect no that's a buddy that's an
institution yeah and listen I love the
guy who runs the FBI now he's a good guy
smart guy lots of Intel cane okay but
but there are Republicans calling for
the FBI to be disbanded yeah well okay
but you can't like like every party's
got stupid people and if that comes from
the president well because the cops are
on to him so we going after the cop let
me tell you something just because
somebody's doing something stupid
thought me this just because someone's
doing something stupid doesn't mean you
have to do something stupid and so the
president says if you don't understand
with the stupid but wait a second but
you you could stand with people on
certain
and be against them on others so when he
says things about Muller I'm on TV
almost every Sunday so I'm saying it's
wrong and when you attack the FBI and
our CIA and our intelligence agencies
rightly that's over what do other
countries think it looks like we're
divided that we're fighting amongst
ourselves that were weak you you have to
be a patriot and say that's wrong I
can't be with that but that's what I
said but it but it also doesn't mean
that the other side's all that enticing
either so everybody makes choices well
and and but they're not only Republicans
get this patriotic community yeah
explain that's me well like if Obama did
the things that the Trump has done if he
said call me was a nutjob I got rid of
him if he stood in the office with the
Russians if he stood in Helsinki and
said well the intelligence AG says this
but Putin's a strong guy he said it very
strongly to me and I believed him right
I don't know why I wouldn't
and then lies about the word would he
would not you don't think you get they
get a pass that's it I think I think if
he had done stuff like that they would
have impeached him and the Democrats may
wind up trying to impeach Trump yeah but
the but at the end of it at the end of
it there is a different standard for
this guy there's no question about that
and it's been a different standard since
the campaign when I ran against him I
mean listen the day that he said that
John McCain wasn't a hero right okay
after a guy spent six years in the Hanoi
cage and was tortured and and and let
yeah and refused to take an early out
because he was the son of an admiral
like I don't know how many boxes you
have to check to be a hero but it seems
to me you checked all of them especially
when Donald Trump is a draft-dodging
what lay boy
let me tell you why new is a different
standard I mean I actually talked to Jeb
Bush that day the day it happened Jeb
called me and said well Trump's gonna be
out of the race now so let's let's be
civil to each other as we go forward
here you and I are gonna be fighting
this thing out let's be civil let's not
get this thing down in the dirt we both
thought he was gone you can't survive
that right and then he did yes
all right so and and and we could go
through a whole bunch of things it
happened after that the American people
have held him to a different standard
than they have held other presidential
candidates and now other presidents
that's just the reality of it we watch
it happen and that's the reality of it
so I know you can be moan it but it's
not just him it's it's it's the fact
that he's been held to a different
standard by the media and by others when
he was a candidate he was a list and
'red right that's my point yeah that's
my point it's like I wouldn't have
gotten away with saying that about no
Jeff no she wouldn't go away with saying
that John McCain okay all right maybe
he's crazy
no you've answered my question and I
appreciate that so you get one last easy
one okay what I love the Mets and you
love the men yeah I got my Mets
cufflinks I'm ready okay why do you love
the mess I love the mess because I was 7
years old in 1969 and they won the World
Series and I thought this is the way
it's gonna be forever and 50 years later
they've won one more time so you know
but but I is the only sports team in my
house with that all four children are
required to root for in basketball
hockey football they can root forever
they want you must root for the Mets of
mine voices we want you let the move for
the Yankees let them be happy and I said
no life life is full of pain and
disappointment they need to learn now
about that
all right Thank You governor come along
watch a game with me
all right Governor Chris Christie just
took out
you